Ici de la campagne,
j'ai grandi dans les valeurs
représentées et défendues par l'alliance rural.
Si j'ai décidé de m'engager avec l'alliance rural,
c'est pour faire entendre
et soutenir le milieu agricole
qui subit des attaques sans
précédent depuis plusieurs années.
Nous ne sommes plus libres d'exercer le métier
comme bon nous semble
mais certains sont
persuadés de savoir à notre place
et veulent nous apprendre notre métier
qui est pour 1ère objectif de nourrir la population.
Les normes, les pressions médiatiques,
l'agribaching
alimentent le prétendu savoir
de ceux qui n'ont jamais mis les pieds dans les champs
et ce jusqu'à diviser les personnes du milieu rural
entre elles. Il ne faut pas écouter les fausses
informations mais plutôt se renseigner et
comprendre pourquoi le métier a choisi ses façons de
travailler.
Ce métier qui fluctue en fonction des prix mondiaux,
de la météo,
sans aucune stabilité d'une année sur l'autre
n'a pas besoin de plus de pression.